on vend des horreurs mais on voit aussi
de très jolies choses à lure cierges
multicolores médaille boule à neige ou
vierge clignotantes à lourdes depuis
les produits dérivés jalonnent l'arrivée
au sanctuaire un business juteux pour
les centaines de commerçants de la cité
mariale d'une grosse clientèle dit oui
énormément
des palourdes fond c'est le miracle
compte en moyenne 6 millions de pèlerins
chaque année acheteurs potentiels de
gadgets religieux un commerce de la
piété que certains dénonçaient dès les
années 70 un ecclésiastique remettait
même les pendules à l'heure c'est dans
le but d'éviter une exploitation du
sentiment religieux et une déviation
superstitieuse notamment de la part de
la publicité qui tendrait à faire croire
que porter un objet rattaché à lourdes
donnerait automatiquement le bonheur
nous n'avons pas le droit de laisser
faire cela car nous sommes des
éducateurs de la fois parfois qualifiée
de marchands du temple les commerçants
lourdais défendez alors leur légitimité
dans la cité mariale
les commerçants lourde et font partie
intégrante de leur cité il s'efforce je
pense de remplir au mieux leur mission
d'accueil et de compréhension vis-à-vis
de leurs hôtes
et du côté des visiteurs les avis sont
aussi parfois mitigés
attention de la grotte il faut lever les
yeux au ciel mais on peut pas regarder
pousser magasin parce que ça ne sert à
rien de scandaleux sur le blond les jeux
c'est tout à fait indépendant des
sanctuaires peuvent empêcher les gens de
voitures des commerces des commerces
bâti sur l'eau de la grotte où aurait eu
lieu les apparitions de la vierge en
1858 si les marchands lourdais ont
interdiction de l'avant bras les flacons
et bidons à l'effigié de la vierge marie
font en revanche partie de leurs
best-sellers
mais cette marchandisation était encore
une fois pointé du doigt en 1989 cette
eau n'est pas une au match
c'est dieu qui guérit ce n'est pas l'eau
à mende même 26 ans plus tard malgré
l'interdiction les bidons remplis d'eau
de lourdes se vendent désormais sur
internet
dix fois plus cher qu'en magasin la
différence de prix c'est le temps c'est
le temps qu'on passe en réalité c'est ce
qu'on voit c'est le temps que l'on passe
pour aller faire tout ça passe autrement
pour les vendre au même prix du magasin
mais vide auquel cas ça n'intéresserait
personne
la frénésie commerciale qui entoure ce
lieu de pèlerinage l'un des plus
importants au monde n'est pas du goût du
pape françois il appelle à plus de
dévotion et moins de business dans le
célèbre sanctuaire français
[Musique]